Dirk gently's holistic detective agency  sum up the plot it's very cool it's very  complicated  yeah the plot is essentially it is let  me see if I can do this it is about a  detective called Dirk Gently  each season is a new case and it's  seemingly a combination of various  elements that are sort of tangentially  not related to one another it's it's  suddenly becoming very very chaotic as  the episodes go along new things are  introduced as other things are solved  and then it all comes together at the  end to sort of coalesce and show you  that everything was actually because  there's also there's kind of a Doctor  Who vibe a little bit but but Doctor Who  on some sort of strange powerful  prescription medicine totally yeah a  little Doctor Who on acid and yeah it's  really insane wouldn't say I asked it  again  okay but kids booze is far boozes stick  with the theme yeah we did  you